ça fait quoi d'être la seule rousse à la
télévision non il ya il ya franck de la
personne aussi merde j'ai dit ça on a
déjà beaucoup de demandes et ouais quand
tu vas justement chez l'esthéticienne
sans supporters est un art s il est
gentil
oui j'ai enregistré mon finissent là
parce que ça fait très mal
mais je vois pas en quoi je suis
vulgaire je vois plein de joie plein
d'hommes s'approprier ce genre de
l'image d'expression et c'est pas
tellement transgressif je pense juste
dans la bouche d'une femme ça gêne un
peu plus et en fait c'est très c'est
très dérangeant quand on me dit ça parce
que d'un côté je sais que les gens qui
me le disent c'est pas il n'y a pas
d'intention méchant derrière ça mais ça
veut dire que quelque part si tu es
mignonne et marrante et bien il faut pas
te salir ou est tu dois donner un
discours aseptisé où être plus propre
alors que des fois il y a que le mot
merde qui correspond et que le mot c'est
de la merde moi je vois des choses qui
me dérangent sur d'autres chaînes où les
des propos nauséabonds j'ai pas d'autre
mot
j'ai pas envie de minimiser parce que je
suis une fille je fais souvent des
sketches où je parle de moi ou des trucs
que je peux vivre mon intimité de pas
vraiment mon intimité intimité mais si
je vais parler d'épilation de rupture de
oued de syndrome prémenstruel et charge
mentale
bonjour marlène schiappa et bien les
gens vont trouver enfin les gens les
gens vont croire que c'est trash or ça
fait partie de ma vie et celle de
vraiment une grande partie de l'humanité
donc je pense que c'est bien d'en parler
et il ya beaucoup de jeunes garçons qui
me regardent ils me disent merci grâce à
toi j'ai pu pécho parce que je sais ce
que c'est qu'une femme et pour ça je
suis contente
donc comment se détacher de l'image de
miss météo c'est pas si dur c'est plus
dur de se détacher d'un radiateur par
exemple si non tu es tu tu écris tu tu
cherches moi j'ai juste été à la radio
j'ai repris le truc
le problème à l'envers c'est juste que
j'ai fait cette année qui était hyper
formatrice et j'ai appris plein de
choses je sui bat yam maintenant tu vas
chercher qui tu es
sans l'aide de personne tu va tester des
trucs donc j'ai testé des chansons je me
suis éclaté je travaille des gens
différents c'était c'était passionnant
6-2 oublier complètement l'image
justement dégager tout ce qui est
voilà tout ce qui est superficiel et
travail que ton texte est à voir comme
si tu devais choisir en fait c'est une
question qui est très embarrassante et
pas très très moderne qui serait
peut-être temps d'arrêter de la pause et
ouais quand on te dit oui il ya peu de
femmes humoristes alors qu'en fait il y
en a plein et tu entends des fois des
et personne ne te dire tu es drôle pour
une fille au début tu éclaté après
c'était une insulte en fait parce que ça
veut dire pour une fille c'est minimiser
le le truc
et surtout il ya plein de femmes qui
sont drôles c'est jusque on a grandi
avec avec des époques où en fait le
premier atout de séduction s'était pas
où l' arme de séduction s'était pas
l'humour c'était le physique
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que ça
peut aussi très bien convenir à une
femme
j'espère